there are no winners only losers in the
sad ordeal after the reviewing the facts
of this case and the applicable state
law I have determined that it is not in
the best interest of justice to pursue
prosecution of Miss Jones on the
misdemeanor charge for which she was
indicted by the grand jury therefore I
am here by dismissing this case and no
further legal action will be taken
against Miss Jones in this matter it is
important to point out that our decision
my decision not to prosecute Miss Jones
is in no way a criticism of the
hard-working and conscientious members
of the Jefferson County investment
cutoff grand jury who answered the call
to public duty these citizens took the
evidence presented by them by the
pleasant world Police Department and
made what they feel is to be a
reasonable decision to indict Miss Jones
the members of the grand jury took to
heart that the life of an unborn child
was violently ended and someone believes
someone should be held accountable but
in the interest of all concern we are
not prosecuting this case and I have
taken the stand that this office will no
longer would no further prosecute this
matter
but those grand jury members heard
literally hundreds of cases presented to
them in April and I want to sincerely
thank them for their service and I want
to thank you for being here no questions
will be asked at this time